getting the runaround from the FBI and
DOJ Devin Nunez went straight to the
Director of National Intelligence dan
coates today Nunez had given the
agency's a 5 p.m. deadline to turn over
key documents in the Russia and Hillary
Clinton investigations I would say we
cleaned up most of what was on the table
except for the most important piece did
you or did you not run informants into
the Trump campaign especially before the
investigation even began very simple
question it deserves a very simple
answer
well the FBI responded late tonight
saying they've already responded to
Nunez request congressman mark Meadows
joins us now to respond that just
happened apparently congressman so
you're you guys are and got all the
documents you're entitled to well the
one good thing that the FBI and DOJ is
very good at is creative writing you
know anytime that you would suggest that
we have all the documents when we have
tens of thousands of documents that have
not been delivered as we speak right now
we have a valid subpoena that has not
been really responded to appropriately
and it's 97 days and ticking and so for
them to suggest that we have everything
is just factually incorrect Kevin Kline
Smith yes about Kevin Kline Smith well
obviously Chuck Ross did our own deck of
card for anything that just identifying
because we all there are lots of cast
aquarii you've got quite the Love Boat
yeah Sally Moyer you've got all these
different individuals think there is one
common theme and it's called bias bias
against this president he's an FBI he
was Attorney amber and it was actually
attorney number two what we believe the
IG report Chuck Ross and the the IG has
not confirmed that that's what we
suspect but Chuck Ross did some great
reporting today and and said that
actually he was the one that was
interviewing Papadopoulos and so here
you have someone who was key to opening
the investigation in this whole Donald
Trump Russian collusion narrative that
never happened and yet you've got
someone with inherent bias that it
started it's just extremely troubling
now Klein Smith like Moyers
is evidencing bias through various text
messages that were released right I mean
a lot of text messages so it's in it's
not just the text messages it's the fact
that they were key components of an
investigation that Peter struck was
involved with so it's it's all of them
coming together with you know not one
not two but five people that were biased
against this president and yet
initiating the very investigation so
here's the interesting thing Laura what
we've got to do as as as a country is
become transparent give us the documents
let us put them out to the American
people let them judge for themselves
well what is right and what's wrong it's
it's time I've said this before the the
DOJ and FBI has an opportunity to either
be part of the cleanup crew show last
week and he seemed okay we're working on
getting these documents and Jeff doesn't
know what's going on that's he not well
he's recused himself that's right
they're kids but but he's really recused
himself from in any knowledge of what's
going on and so rod Rosen Stein knows
better I mean he really does know better
and and the buck stops with him and I
can tell you that we're going to have
four action this week Laura this week on
the House floor where we compel them to
turn over those documents so just so
people know Klein Smith is the one who
wrote viva la resistance well that's
what if he is indeed attorney which we
be this is a really dumb question but
why is it that we can't identify
attorneys working for that I mean
they're not exactly undercover agent
working in typically yet the nail on the
head actually they're not part of the
counterintelligence division which they
we're trying to pass them on so we're
trying to say with the IG they're
actually part of the general counsel's
office and so an attorney working for
the FBI normally is not an undercover
operation and certainly wasn't here news
tonight that Eric Prince's computers
have been seized and so forth any
thoughts on that well I I think more
Blackwater's so what you see is Bob
Muller continuing to grab information
and and collect information by the way
got 1.2 million documents from Donald
Trump in 90 days and yet they can't turn
over 50 thousand documents to Congress
in nine months there's a problem what's
next for newness after the 5:00 p.m.
deadline they didn't give him anything
said you got everything what's next well
I think the next thing is for floor
action for all of us where I'll do that
well if he made a promise to Jim Jordan
and I last week that said if we didn't
get all the documents by Friday that we
would see for action this week I'm
waiting for him to follow through on
that commitment but if he doesn't we
have he's a man of his word he'll follow
through we're gonna count on that Shawn
we're gonna count on that this week
congressman thanks so much thank you
another deadline passed